hey what's up party people welcome back
to wanted trailer commentaries live and
in studio yeah the second time oh yeah
we made it uh we made it out of our
homes and into i don't know what camera
i'm supposed to look at probably this
one right the smaller one in the middle
i think is there's an enormous screen
with my own face on it just over here so
i'm just going to be staring off camera
slightly perfect there i am uh hey
so we're going to talk about that on
this trailer today for uncharted uh give
you all of our deep thoughts about this
super deep movie that had a lot to
really dig into and discuss and think
about
papa john's
deleted scenes
uh answer fan questions so keep those
coming in the chat and uh if we have
time left and i'll make sure we do we're
gonna talk about the avatar teaser
because we didn't have a chance to do
that yesterday so uh we begin with
uncharted um
a film that's been almost entirely
memory hold for me by now i
might approach an honest trailer i like
to watch a movie twice i watch it once
um as a normie would
with like uh you know i have a pen and a
pad but i don't i'm not really stopping
and starting and taking notes it's just
like letting it wash out let it wash
over you as if i were a person watching
a movie uh
try to put ourselves in one of the the
minds of you the the regular
the the common man
and that said by the end of my first
watch of one of these films i usually
have some like impressions some broad
feelings how it made me feel what i
thought uh maybe a light plot outline
something like that i had nothing at the
end of uncharted i wrote i think i wrote
movie
and you were right it is
ship big
treasure movie um wow this movie was
like a it wasn't terrible
definitely wasn't great i'm gonna have
to disagree with you man
okay it's terrible in what it represents
which is like this is a completely
paint by numbers algorithmically
produced
motion picture with nothing to say and
not even like compelling action or
comedy
agreed
maybe i'm used to that maybe that's just
the way things are see you next time
folks
we did it we solved movies
oh yeah okay well what do you think did
you know what did you like you kind of
charted you charted a little bit oh my
god i was like i was surprised i was
very surprised at how much um i liked it
and i think you like what tom holland i
do like that tom holland
he's 18 right yeah i do honestly it's
totally legal to dunk him and stuff
yeah yeah no like it was uh you know um
tom holland
being not doing marty mcfly this time
which was a pleasant change of pace i
think i mistakenly called that great
acting and then spencer
uh definitely let me know i was wrong i
don't know if that i don't even i take
issue with the fact that he wasn't doing
like his usual schtick he was they just
kind of aged him up a little bit that
made him so i mean it's so awkward
because he looks he does have a total
baby face he has a baby face yeah he's
supposed to be like this i don't know
like gadfly man about time i couldn't
really even figure out who he was
supposed to be like something sometimes
they're playing it like he's still like
he's marty mcfly but from back to the
future three like a little older a
little wiser a little more seasoned even
though in in continuity that's like two
weeks after will give him lessons
but uh but then some other times yeah
he's like already basically proto nathan
drake like he's already good at parkour
and the kicking ass he loves the sauce
he loves drinking yeah and he likes to
flip you know he does the cocktail tom
cruise tricks with the with the alcohol
bottle so yeah it's a little muddled i
feel like even that they didn't really
figure out like it it sort of can't
decide is this just the first nathan
drake inventory because he's already he
arrives basically fully for him what
this is is a uh someone at sony said
people love tom holland what do we have
that we can yeah put them in oh 100 well
we have this uncharted movie it's about
like two guys in their like 30s or 40s
um they're both grizzled explorers let's
age one of them down and just make it it
was absolutely that it was just weird
like you could do a prequel but you also
have to do like young sully and the
other all the other uh characters from
my favorite tv show young sully yeah
i put much as sully
yeah that's begins
him going to flight school um
uh another successful landing facility
credits also alongside where he picks
out which sandwich he wants from the uh
from the deli county yeah weird choice
but i think in retrospect all they
wanted to do was do a tom holland thing
and by that metric it worked because
this made uh a bunch of money so i'm sad
yeah i mean i want people to make money
but not not like this
it reinforces every bad impulse i mean
that that's to me this is just like this
is every one of these big movies that
comes out now where they're trying to
hit four quadrants and they want it to
sell globally so it could be an
international hit so it's it's a little
funny but not really it's a little bit
of action but not really there's a heist
but we're not that into it we haven't
put that much thought like the heist at
some points is literally like them
running across a hallway like everything
is kind of like half-assed you pointed
out that the heist does rely on a moment
where a security guard agrees to just
and then he walks out and it's like
there's so many scenes like that like
the one when i the first time i watched
it one one scene really stood out to me
and made me laugh a lot and it was my
favorite part and it's when mark
wahlberg is trying to solve the puzzle
of how the cross turns into a key
and he's like and you realize that in
in most movies where you're watching
like pretty good actors they like invest
you in the solving of the puzzle i was
thinking of harrison ford in uh indiana
jones and last crusade when he's in the
library in venice and it's like oh the
the roman numeral on the ground is on
that column and oh i got a dig here and
harrison ford acts it so you're like
following him on the process of him
figuring out this puzzle and mark
wahlberg is just i don't know he just he
woke up too early that morning the look
on his face that he's uh always trying
to decipher something yeah but he's just
like oh okay that kind of looks like a
ladder which is just like this cross so
this must be a key and it's like i don't
i just don't buy this on the most core
level isn't doing the thing that those
movies are supposed to i don't buy that
mark wilbur's thinking hard about it
he's just i don't buy that he's solving
this puzzle in real time and if you
can't sell me on that that's uncharted i
mean that's the whole thing well a lot
of it was just like taking the keys and
banging them together together much like
one of those wind-up monkeys yeah and
like that's how they figured it they
were like oh well you just put the keys
on top of them and then they have sex
because it's like it's not really that
kind of it it's it's a it's sort of
leaning in a national treasure-esque
direction but it's not committing to it
because it's not committing to anything
it's trying to be 18 things at once and
so it's nothing
speaking of which let's watch our own
trailer
uncharted we'll stop and go oh boy
from the disney of gaming and the ea of
film comes a swashbuckling romp about a
buff dude a smaller quippy guy and a
sexy lady with an accent to hunt down a
mythical treasure
red notice i i mean jungle cruise no
wait i mean
ah since when did bad versions of the
mummy become its own genre
it was last year
last year
uh we're doing a movie fight i mean i've
decided
all right all right um you don't have to
roll the thing it's fine
full screen junkies movie fights
all right all right ran the thing um
i'll pick last because i'm coming up
with the question uh uncharted red
notice or jungle cruise what's the
better film
let's we'll put a couple minutes on the
clock and fight it out well i i i mean
if i can go first i have to say
uncharted oh i'm definitely going jungle
cruise oh i get red notice great yeah
okay uh yeah we'll just do this for a
couple minutes go for it um you know one
of the benefits of uncharted is that
aside from a wet tom holland which again
is a selling point um it does
there is a lot of action you do see a
lot of these set pieces um there is a
boat there is a there is a boat
confirmed hold on hold on there's a boat
there's a jungle there's a there's no no
no there's a gala there's a gala there's
a gala
i thought it was like a like a
scientific society no it's an auction
right yeah they're auctioning off the
the mcgowan okay that's a guy that's a
girl
they're all in suits it's very fancy
there's a bar there's another guy
there's an artifact yeah but what the
other ones don't have is
that thank you what the other ones don't
have that this has is that tom holland
clearly went to cocktailing school oh
yeah and learned the art of cocktailing
there's also a lot of sliding on things
they spend a lot of time sliding on the
hoods of hoods of cars they slide down
things sometimes they slide up things
sometimes they slide into things and
your movies thank you
all right lon you're a jungle cruise
yeah i i think to me like the one thing
that says jungle cruise just the just
the tiniest bit of park it's not that
much better is is like there there's
guys like jessie plemons paul giamatti
edgar ramirez they're they're trying
they're bringing that they're bringing
supporting character actor energy
into into the mix and it's like it's
something it's it's not as good as a
real movie but it is something and and
uncharted you get antonio banderas in
there as the bad guy and i kept waiting
for them to give him literally one thing
to do or say
it does not happen there's really not a
lot of life
behind the eyes of this one i will say
in in in defense of that um our copy did
not have spanish subtitles so i'm not
entirely sure what happened but
i'm fluent enough in spanish to
understand that he and his dad were
talking about like you have to get them
yeah oh man i thought you were saying
padre like a like a catholic like a like
father no no they're they're this
dynasty that's always had this treasure
oh and he was trying to like impress he
did sometimes it's yeah you needed this
update impress his dad right it's like
i'm gonna get this back i'm gonna save
our family fortune it's that's it's that
vibe um okay well
red notice look
you got terranea that's an excellent
tequila you got aviation
that's a high quality top-shelf alcohol
right there if only you had tom holland
to mix them for you it would be perfect
they go together so well um
look uh ryan reynolds is saying a ton of
things with the cadence of a joke
[Laughter]
with the same pattern and like the
things that sound like set up set up
punchline
um the the rock there's a twist you know
he's not actually an fbi agent uh who
travels the world for interpol and
specializes in art crime who could have
seen that coming from the opening scene
where the interpol lady is like you know
there's no record of you in any fbi
database shut up woman let's go in here
uh you've got um you've got
unforgettable villains like soto voce
i love that you came up with soto
he's uh he's well done yeah he's he's he
strangles people sounds like this yeah
uh and and um
i'll say this about uh about uh red
notice um it's on netflix and you can
play it at 1.5 speed and it pairs
perfectly with you two stories true
story i will say at least with mine this
could be a point for or against there is
no rock both of yours are rockheads you
know with mine antonio banderas gets
completely deep blue seed which is like
my favorite thing which is uh what i
call a deep blue sea is when someone is
in the middle of a village i have to
explain myself in the middle of a
villain speech or in the middle of this
like like oh we're raw rawing the troops
or whatever and then just merked yeah
yeah amazing um all right
uh finally now we'll let the audience
decide who do you who do you who are you
going what's the best out of these three
disasters all right let's keep playing
this trailer
games make you feel like you're playing
an action movie now the big screen
adaptation has arrived and you'll feel
like you're watching someone else play
uncharted while you fall asleep on their
couch that plucks a few cool moments
from the games
and scrambles everything else into a
bland cinematic paste but hey everyone
loves an unfaithful game adaptation
right
right
right
no and why did this one get a pass are
you that horny for spider-man do better
humanity
so i think this
probably wouldn't have done as well
which means it never would have happened
but i do think that there's a good
version of this movie where you do the
marvel thing where you get nolan north
and you make him get abs you just force
some forces just do whatever they do to
kumail to uh hemsworth to to
what's that right
steroids is what they called yesterday
just a lot of steamed chicken and cardio
yeah all right that's that's how it
works folks uh i think you could have
done that to to nolan north and had like
a great grizzled adventurer that people
would have dug but but he's so great in
his cameo as man vacationing alone in
the philippines
nothing questionable there
that's in the start
um oh that's right
yeah all right let's steal our thunder
from
i just think that i think that this
would have been a
uncharted 4 again is a movie you're
playing through it yeah it's not all the
uncharted games are like you could you
could adapt any of the uncharted games i
was even saying even the first one ends
with that big seaplane falling down the
waterfall thing like that could have
been in a movie yeah but i think that
oddly uh this movie was like semi-low
budget so maybe you couldn't have
actually pulled off a lot of the
uncharted but you save a lot of money by
hiring nolan north over tom holland and
mark wahlberg i mean
you could tell that it's a little low
but just like i said it's an action
movie where they they are very efficient
about where the actual action beats go
there really are only a few big set
pieces
most of it is just them in like a room
or a set bickering and that's how they
were able to sort it but i still feel
like you could have adapted the games
using that same strategy yeah
uh all right let's keep going
parker with a fake id after growing
roughly five years from his childhood
flashback they become one of those
bartenders who thinks of themselves as
more of a mixologist a negroni first
made in 1919 for count camillo negroni
when he swapped the soda water in his
usual drink cocktails the americana
in between shaking appletinis he's also
become a self-taught history these are
served in martini glasses and not the
glass i looked it up you can do it
i i wish they got that wrong but you can
do it in either oh really that's
acceptable all right
parkour expert who definitely knows how
to shoot a guard
oops i was thinking of the games again
silly me no this version just knows how
to chew some gum
what a classic character there's no
payoff you keep wait because they do it
so much you're like there's got to be a
gum thing like he needs it to save the
day but do they really have to treat it
to do something
he uses it to plug a door but like not
in an important one that's like early on
there's still more gum callbacks
yeah no it's not it's not a it's yes
there is there's a lot of mentions of
gum but there's no like crucial here's
why this gum thread has been running
through the hole and it gets at the
whole like um i don't know schizophrenia
of the thing where you're trying to make
him like an adult like a grown man but
also a child like don't give him a
bubble gum habit if you're also trying
to make him like i love hubba bubba it's
like you are a grown man yeah
i need to see your id and then it
becomes a point of contention too like
mark wahlberg's like real men don't chew
bubble gum it's like is that a thing is
that a trope like dudes like gum right
fellas is it gay that you go
is what we're asking
keep going
buff little toddler the whole time
you're still working on the tie i just
can't figure out you work in a fancy bar
yeah shirley temple it's hilarious
puberty's right around the corner kids
you can grow your own
when you put boston and a crucifix in
your script you summon mark wahlberg and
when marky mark remarks on nate's mark
here's the right mark he'll deny marky
mark's mark remarks i'm not a mark in
some bar but when marky mark remarks on
your mark mark my words your marky
mark's next mark watch them form a mini
me even mini or me relationship they're
only like one inch taller than me as
this charming one-dimensional actor
shows tom holland his acting future you
think that i know something
[Laughter]
did you really just ask me that bravo
gentlemen
powerful stuff
your woman into the mix with all the
depth and backstory of a cave troll one
day i found a bronze statue covered in
gems buried under a bridge it'll kick
off a non-stop freeway of double
you can't leave me you let her take the
cross you'll let her take it pause give
it to you oh yeah pause this is the bulk
of the movie yeah three of them being
like who's working with who who's on
whose side can you trust me trust me
throw me the thing i can't trust you
give me the thing first and then i'll
give you the yeah you throw me the idol
i throw you the whip
extended yeah
yeah and then you'd have to say it twice
because they do everything like johnny
two times two times oh yeah yeah very
big
yeah it just really it's it's really the
minimum viable product to get you from
one scene to the next which is like a
little talk about trusting a little a
little back and forth insult and then a
parkour and then you're on to the next
it also made me feel like they're taking
a lot of weird cues from the pirates of
the caribbean franchise there's like all
the big ship stuff and that's like the
big finish is like this pirate sequence
and then that's their bit it's like the
endless oh i'm betraying you and parlay
and oh i'm gonna go over here and work
with him and now he's here and it's just
like it it doesn't really even work
there like even in the pirates movies i
remember us sitting around being like oh
this is kind of all just goes around in
circles afterwards but even in the
pirates movies you have people with uh
distinct and competing motivations these
are i guess you have like with with this
movie it's his brother which he didn't
even mention because that's how
interesting it is
really setting that up for the next one
i think is like
the payoff for that one doesn't come yet
like orlando bloom and johnny depp have
like very different you know
points of view and reasons why they're
trying to find these different treasures
and this is just like
vaguely like they want them to be
morally gray but they're afraid to make
them actually bad but they want you to
like everybody and they just but they
just want the gold yeah who cares i
don't care why any of them get there
it's the thing the uncharted games do
better is how sully is like legitimately
allowed to be more of a gray area kind
of character and in this yeah they wanna
you gotta you gotta love like i love him
it's just like you gotta love everybody
it's just a bunch of people who want to
get rich which is like well that's
everybody like i don't that doesn't yes
we would all like to have a bunch of
gold i did appreciate that there's no no
character who is like the
hey we should give this gold back to
like the people that it was stolen from
like what's her name um
they're all i i wrote them down as girl
one and girl yeah which is bad
don't but i did i wrote them down as
girl one and girl two um but chloe had
that moment where she was like yeah you
know i found that thing under the bridge
and i was hoping we would give it to a
museum but my dad was like pawning
pawnee pond and and i'm waiting for the
moment where she's like so i wanna maybe
take this and blah blah it's like no dad
taught me a great lesson
no one is like oh we're gonna put it
under we'll take it around the world and
show these treasures they belong to
everybody like there's no character like
that it's all just like no i'm gonna
take them and put them in my vault and
truly would be giving this movie far too
much credit to think that they were
making a commentary on magellan than the
age of explorers also robbing cultures
of their gold so it's like they know
that they just they just ignore the
subtext ignored it entirely yeah all
right anyway keep playing
right
yeah i might let her steal the wrong
coordinates
in a quick field face-off over actual
crosses give me a cross i'm not giving
you my cross why would i do that you
don't need them both give me the cross
you haven't said please throw your key
down you two think you're gonna
double-cross me you want the stupid gear
you want the gold so give me the key
yeah it goes on like this for like 90
minutes trust me we're gonna have to
figure out a way to trust each other
she's not to be trusted the minute you
start to trust someone you lose you can
trust me trust me well you don't trust
me well you don't trust me i don't trust
anybody it's five billion in gold just
split it three ways morons what are you
trying to do by twitter yeah yeah yeah
that was that was kind of funny that
they
made it five billion yeah like you could
just
like rewards have to you know we got
inflation we're dealing with that right
now and stuff like that but like
make it up make it 500 million and then
there's like maybe an argument for why
three ways like you'd want more you get
greedy but what's 5 billion divided by 3
oh i mean yeah they're all getting 1.6
1.7 billion yeah yeah i think i think
20. well you got to be carl icahn
you're all just buying like henley's and
like uh and you know fancy liquor
shakers
yeah what is tom holland's ultimate
ownership dream in this like
he needs to buy like a chain of islands
like what is this well he needs more
like stuff for him to like do workouts
on because they have that whole sequence
for no good reason where he i guess just
to be like oh look he can leap people
are going to be asking like how he can
climb things if we don't show him
practicing in his environment he does
have a lot of just like native parkour
skills like like this movie is assuming
a lot of young people are just walking
around with the ability to do parkour
yeah and like never never using it
because they have it in case there was a
they were almost setting it up to be
like okay he probably went into like a
life of crime right because he's like
he's like ripping people off yeah he's
like a pickpocket yeah and he was i
guess in an orphanage growing up with
his
raised by nuns but raised by full-on i
was expecting yeah like full-on oliver
twisting like this is how i've been yeah
he's like
conditioning like yeah doing pull-ups on
the lamp post and stuff like that but
instead he's just like it was a g
bartender there was an artful dodger
character in between there maybe yeah
uh all right let's keep playing for a
globetrotting adventure but like the
kind where you stay in hostels to cut
costs as nate and sully travel from the
kitty gut wet bar in manhattan to
spain's most ancient papa john's i'm
like literally in a papa john's right
now to a cave with not one
two
is that what kind of papa john's is that
is that a sit down papa john's do they
have those in europe i just assumed that
uh like mcdonald's overseas is like a
lot nicer playing right no this is i'm
not i'm not doubting i'm genuinely
curious because it looks like if you
were like i'm in a pizza hut there are
they we used to have pizza huts in
america oh they were great sitting down
it was like a restaurant
pan pizza oh the red car the red cups
right but never but never papaji that
was never a papa john's thing well uh
tell us um viewers if you are currently
in or around barcelona what's the pump
and jobs
are you often in fast food type places
where they just have like frescoes from
hundreds of years ago preserved behind
like a thin layer of plastic untouched
ancient murals is that a thing in
barcelona i think any of these older
cities you know barcelona paris uh
london there's always an adventurer um
kind of crashing through every time
you're in a coffee bean there's just
like a guy in a hat with a whip
but one of the moon knights comes in
there he's trying to tries to dictate no
uh friend of the show if he wadi way is
in europe right now we should ask him
yeah let's let's
dial in from uh
madrid yeah burger king let's see what
he can find
okay let's like find the place in
amsterdam where they got the nepalese
space cakes in atlanta and go underneath
there and there's definitely buried
treasure
old boats inside suck it goonies all
stitched together by a thin paste of
banter parkour and blues clues level
puzzles in a film that doesn't even try
to justify why two boston jabrones can
steal another country's gold for
themselves what are you some kind of
professor or something just shut up and
fill your cargo pants okay and while
you're at it say hello to your brother
stay out of your brother for me will you
hey that's my line lady
so fly through an adventure so average
netflix is using it to train their ai
that writes their movies that's not so
much a prequel of uncharted as it is a
frankenstein's monster of uncharted 4. a
bad photocopy of indiana jones nuns why
is it always gotta be nice when did you
decide to become indiana jones and the
soft launch of the playstation cinematic
universe uh pass but how much cooler
would it have been if they crossed it
over with i don't know god of war saints
row and assassin's creed what the hell
happened to youtube that doesn't count
i think a god of war movie would be
awesome and i think that they should
just do that without
effing it up i think they should just i
think they are doing it yeah yeah it's
one of those ones that's yeah that's
that's in development right now
but they won't uh so what's the what's
the ruined god of war going on you're a
god of war you're a god of war i'm a god
of war you think you're a god of war i
gotta go find the god of war yeah we
gotta go find athena's bow and arrow
okay
and yeah there's gonna be a little parts
of the map but we need to go get the
fourth and the fifth yeah he's gonna use
um
i don't know some kind of like like
blunt stick weapon or something the
entire movie and then he's gonna get
knives with chains on them at some point
and go nah
put them to the side of this i mean it's
also regular looking kratos and then
when he get like there's a moment in the
movie where he adopts the familiar look
now yeah puts the the before he was
kratos yeah he was actually this chuck
it's going to be like a cut on the eye
or something that makes the blood oh
yeah yeah it writes itself at this point
folks i am i will say uh they've got the
guy craig mason who did chernobyl is
doing the last of us show for hbo max
yeah that could be good he's great hbo
gonna have great production values i do
feel like there's a good chance that's
going to be cool
there's a deep a decent chance um craig
mason uh also uh hangover too um
and he's doing the borderlands movie
interesting yeah yeah um
all right well okay here we go
also who should play crash bandicoot
that's the movie fight that's the movie
fight question that's a great question
who should play crash bandicoot not
chris i mean
john cena is the obvious choice because
the jorts connection
obviously obviously she works on shorts
you want someone more feral um
yeah they got to be like you got to bed
that mannequin
is a great choice galifianakis man is
that kind of a comedian i think or it
could just be colin farrell like he he
keeps you know doing his different
you're doing his different suit stuff
what are you doing what are you showing
me here come on
i'm spinning over here
oh man
just as penguin call him carol's penguin
[Laughter]
keep playing
peter parker
so much sliding
is he so wet
slippery went away
we got a lot of mileage over the years
out of that office parkour hold open
there's so much more glitters
in suits
never say die
grey's archaeology
nolan north on vacation by himself in
the philippines hmm
uncharted fans when they watch this
movie so
drake drake drake
and oh crap remastered holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
tom raider oh crap
now um
wait a minute naughty dog the company
exists in this world what games do they
make
yeah so this is this is a it's nice but
i do like the other tag we wrote better
um but
i don't want to i didn't want to get
pulled because it's the it's the tom
holland dancing to umbrella
thing and we've just had some some uh
parental guidance and copyright uh flags
lately so yeah didn't want to tempt the
robots yeah jackass really um yeah
jackass and uh and vox machina really
put us on the on the bad side of
youtube's content wow i'm not happy um
yeah i guess for r-rated movies we'll
just show a different movie and talk
about something
the
else
well showgirls makes sense
makes sense yeah yeah yeah um did we i
forget did we put hal's face on all the
boobs and show girls yes yes we did okay
yeah
that's a step two too much
too much
uh meanwhile the the montage of uh
everyone well no okay so in saw we had
this horrible montage that i'd watch
unedited of just all the glorious yeah
the whole most gruesome strung together
yeah um we blurred the crap out of it
saw ends up getting a strike or whatever
against it because we use a five second
clip of somebody else's footage from saw
the ride the roller coaster like
somebody did some kind of like you know
a pov like i'm on the roller coaster um
and it was honestly less than five
seconds two seconds um and that's what
got saw in trouble so it's a dangerous
game this parody life we live yeah
obviously we would win if we took it to
court but we're not
all right let's watch the uh watch the
delete scenes for uncharted
starring
tom of finland senpai red notice me
danny broshan
the how you say is schmoe
captain hooks
gal gadot nolan
i forgot about the the the henchwoman
who kills the
billionaire boss in the middle yeah in
the middle of the mission and
everybody's like
all right i i guess i work for you now
like if somebody murdered my boss in the
middle a of of work and was like now
it's me
well no well
now you ruined it because i was going to
murder you in the middle of this and now
i am in charge i would probably just i
have to say i would probably just follow
her
she killed you and they were like i'm
the host of uh honest trailers
commentaries now i'd be like so anyway
uncharted i think it's not good
spending is just sitting there on the
desk you know
what else you got i think i gotta say
like the least blood like of i've ever
seen of something like a very bloodless
throat slit yeah very yeah she's she's
very efficient maybe it's like she's
she's so good with those hooks that it's
just a perfectly clean slice you know
yeah yeah she was good with a hook yeah
she's good with a hook well if that's
how i go out um
braddock she's got some like very weird
like she goes only by her like last
night yeah
yeah there's a moment but it's a marky
mark saying it in like a crowded bar and
i can't yeah
her name is girl number one captain she
came
oh she's from sabrina this is the only
thing i know about it yeah
all right let's wrap this up
postcards from the edge lord
gold will hunting
irrational treasure
who charted
i'm not really much of a dancer lies now
dance
and he's playing um
who's he playing in a in a biopic soon
uh
the if you know one guy dancer oh friend
of stairs
yes he's doing the first stairwell oh i
didn't even know that yeah well there
you go yeah so he better could have been
borishikoff
tom holland is doing the crumping movie
uh all right what do we do at this point
in the show i guess we ask questions or
questions are asked of us right we
answer questions we don't ask them
they've been asking forever oh sure yeah
i want to talk let's talk avatar briefly
um i want to go back i want to go back
to pandora
listen this family is our fortress
okay yeah take that audio down yeah and
we'll just briefly
i i mean vibe
my thing about avatar is like it was
always designed for like a big screen
spectacle type experience it's like you
know like captain eo and used to go to
disneyland exactly like that was great
but it wasn't like i want to watch
captain eo 100 times at home on tv i
want to go to disneyland and see the
little monkey guy fly right up into my
face
and i i feel like the same way about
this like i'm obviously going to go see
this in a theater and
marvel at the 3d spectacle and then
never think about it again oh i'm going
to go see it in 40 at least twice yeah
like i want to see it with and i want to
see it with all the stuff this time
that's the face i'm going to see pause
that's the face go back to that face
that's what i want to be doing during my
entire avatar experience it's just the
that look that's the look yeah um as i
just marvel at the things around me i
don't care if there's a plot i don't
care if there's character if jake sully
returns if nati is back oh you named two
characters
i really just want to go through i want
to be a human in an aquarium no i want
to be a navi in an aquarium and just
look at the different fish flora and
fauna exactly
i think that's funny that's one of the
the big knocks against the movie that
people always do is that oh you could we
name a character from you can't name one
character from avatar they say the name
jake sully like a thousand times in the
movie like that's not even it's also
like name a character from the itunes
visualizer like i can't but if i'm on
trooms it's the best thing to ever look
at i mean this is gonna be so this is
different from from a movie this is
i think the most positive version of a
martin scorsese uh uh roller coaster
what does he call marvel movies
yeah i want to get on i want to lower
the the shoulder restraints um i want to
[ __ ] my pants as james cameron has said
yeah and i mean i think people are
remembering or evaluating it based on
like you know it was on you know they
watched it on netflix a few months ago
and it's like well yeah no it wasn't the
experience it's bad like i i think we're
all in agreement that like these are not
like classic films if you had to look up
the just to make sure because it wasn't
on the trailer anywhere but it will be
in 3d it will be an imax 3d of course
don't worry um this will not people
thought they were bringing attitude
itself to the well i i feel like a lot
of theater's probably
scaled back on the number of three yeah
it's less of a it's less of a craze than
it was in 09 yeah well because again
these are different because this is like
it is built for 3d specifically so it's
shot that way yeah that's great again i
want to go into a theater i want to have
everything surround me i want to an
usher to come and spit in my mouth like
i want the entire experience yep okay
well maybe not now
no no no no no no like covered ruins
everything he can show me a recent pcr
test he comes by he shows you a pcr test
and then he gets there he spits in your
mouth starts hawking then he spits in
your mouth all right uh that's enough
avatar too we'll we'll do a deep dive
when there's a trailer that was just a
little tease but man
oh wow
look at that
[Laughter]
you're very puzzled
yeah where are they mystifying um here's
one uh suze vera asks who jumped falling
who jumped up falling stuff better tom
holland and uncharted orlando bloom and
the five armies or mario in an intent in
any nintendo game remember that scene in
in five armies where yeah orlando bloom
is like hopping up was it uh rocks or
orcs yeah
rocks and then or yes i believe there's
a little bit there's a stream i believe
there's both i'm also thinking there's
that shot where he's standing next to a
horse and then he pulls himself up on
the horse one hand you know like he like
slides the horse under him almost which
is that's that shot is better than
anything in uncharted i'm going to give
it to uncharted though because um
tom holland is ostensibly like a human
being with uh with regular yeah
[Music]
has little bird bones they're hollow
he's he's got a lot he's uh he's a very
powerful elf yeah yeah but i feel like
elves are like birds like they have a
holoskeleton so they're very lightweight
and it's easier for them to hop like oh
no they're falling i mean they're
obviously much more yeah stronger and
able to like fling themselves around way
better than they can like yeah they can
just like jumping stand up on the back
of a horse while it's in motion like
yeah you never see like a like an elf
with a dad bod you never see like uh no
like i said no they're yeah they tend to
be you know they're they're wafey
they're all kind of twinks
they are
the five twink army
[Laughter]
but that doesn't speaking of twinks i do
kind of
usually do
i do kind of
i don't want this to happen because it's
like bad and scary but it would be
interesting to watch someone try to rob
tom holland because i do think that he
would parkour away from them you think
he would try to kind of like skip it i
think
i think at this point he has no choice i
think he's so used to it that he would
just like start it's muscle memory
exactly
he would also disarm you with his like
charmingly befuddled like oh oh what are
you you robbing me oh and then like
while you're caught up in that then he
slides yeah hops off the back wall and
he just like slides through your legs
i feel like casino royale came out like
at the height of the parkour craze and
really nailed it and every other movie
since then it kind of feels like they're
trying to just like recapture that
casino royale magic also um
it's a french film uh escape from
district b-13
i think it's just called district
district b-13 yeah yeah that does that
that's like i think they guys got
parkour guys right just like that that's
like the originators of the parkour
actual movement we're doing that um i'm
gonna ask this one just because i want
lon to repeat what he was telling us
before the show uh benzai tennis how'd
you guys like bandit cumberbatch hosting
snl
i saw betty to cover badge said some i
don't know he said something about some
sort of current political issue oh it
was on snl he was talking he was making
fun of the the slap and will smith and
so uh some people on black twitter were
pointing out that if you go back and bet
it to cumberbatch's personal family
history there were slave owners in there
so i looked it up and uh if you go back
like four generations the cumberbatch is
our famous british actors they're like
this very like a british dynastic acting
family and he's like great great
grandfather was acting on the stage in
like the mid 18th century but then yeah
the guy right before all the actors
owned a slave plantation in barbados so
well cumberbatch
bad guys uh
i feel like this season has been a real
like there it feels like it's back in
some way like not that it's consistently
good every but there's like there's good
stuff in it again like sarah sherman's
been really great uh and like the please
just don't destroy guys
and like they've got they've got a
little bit of fresh blood coming in this
year yeah
um okay let's do uh this one chris sears
asked you're writing a heist film
starring nick cage and mark wahlberg
what are they trying to steal who else
is in the movie how many oscars does it
win so we'll try to we'll put our heads
together and try to do a cage wahlberg
well let's let's make it a red notice
let's let's make it a cage wahlberg red
notice sure so
they're archaeologists
one of them is right one of them's dad
was an archaeologist
and he died
and he left
kate he left cage
uh a dinosaur skull with a map on the
inside yeah oh like inside one of the
teeth or something like that yeah yeah
um and then
but it leads to a treasure that was left
on earth by aliens yes yes 100
um and then mark wahlberg comes in
because he is um looking for
not his brother maybe he's like my
daughter went missing because she was
looking for a treasure and then it was
on like the tooth of a blah blah blah
yeah and he's a he's a boston street cop
yes yes yes he's investigating
can i just throw this out there are they
at any point swapping faces because i
feel like
i want to see those two actors do the
face off bit and play one another i
think they gotta swap faces now who is
the um uh woman who can't be trusted who
gets thrust
upon these two oh a woman who can't be
trusted she's got to be because that's
the way that we're doing it now if
they're both white she's got to be
something else because that's that's
just how it works that's true um that's
how it works now that is that's the
formula yeah um aquafina
before you you brought up that excellent
point i was going to say jojo siwa
because i feel like it also has to these
guys are both a little old we need to
get like some younger people in the door
well she's gay so that counts i think
that counts yeah i think it counts
because she's gay yeah i feel like isaac
gonzalez is the actual actor that would
be cast in
like in in 2022 like she's already
auditioning for this even though this
movie doesn't exist
now i know that they both qualify for
this but who is the the antonio banderas
the like older but still recognizable
actor who plays the the heavy or the the
um
the bad guy who's also running a rival
archaeology you know who'd be good as a
as a bad guy in one of these movies i
think is jimin hansu so i'm gonna throw
him out
cause you gotta it's always it's always
like like a mysterious foreign man who's
wealthy and he's got an elaborate
impressive office yeah and like yeah who
do you picture when you're in an
elaborate office of a very sophisticated
foreign gentleman
i'm in a suit yeah
i'm in hanzo in a suit and you're done
finally give me give me one set piece
with cajun wahlberg one stunt or or
situation that is like a watered-down
version of some other movie or something
original that they gotta get through
okay um so
um let's just do a full remix so there
is um a boat in the sky
and there's a mine cart track going next
there's a minecraft truck next to it um
and so they have to um get onto the boat
in the sky because it's the only way
that they can then
get into a uh spaceship
sure yeah
the downed spacecraft that landed at
roswell in the 50s that the cia has
obviously been holding on to this whole
time yeah that's what they're stealing
at the end so they've got to fly that
out of the installation and then it
crashes onto the vegas strip and it
turns out that obviously they crash it
onto the vegas strips
uh and dinosaurs it turns out were the
aliens all along and they they seated
humanity that's so good man
those are people yeah i moon followed it
um all right perfect that's exactly it
uh there's your there's your blue notice
this week we did it for you uh we are
going to be back in here in studio next
week before um not a film but
uh but a red note but a red notice but a
longer red notice
it also includes archaeology
we're never going to escape man there
are artifacts involved
um there's definitely some banter oh
there's some actors that you like um
doing things you don't
that's your clue for next week thanks so
much for watching we had fun didn't you
everyone belong had fun we'll see you
next week australia commentaries
[Music]
you